>> So, know that we know a bit more about your Y Chromosome
in your paternal line, would do you
know about your Mitochondria, you maternal line?
>> Well, if we look over here, back to MY RESULTS and then under
ANCESTRY OVERVIEW. If you click on the MATERNAL LINE, I found
out. That, I am J2a1a, a subgroup of J2.
>> Wow! And where's this from?
>> So this
basically shows that it's from the Northwestern
portion of Asia in the Middle East.
>> Wow, this seems maybe a little surprising or, or not?
>> it's very surprising, I mean
[SOUND],
like I've mentioned earlier I, hypothesized that both my maternal
and paternal line were all from the North, Northern Europe.
>> And it says here that the Haplogroup J originated
about 45,000 years ago. On the Arabian Peninsula, just as
modern humans were first expanding out of Africa. I mean
that sounds, I mean this is some deep history. Some.
>> Eh.
>> Some deep Ancestry here.
>> I never could imagine that I would find out
information about my ancestors that, that far.